hey everybody welcome to another
rollback Audio Only episodes from the
early days of the podcast brought to you
here on YouTube for the very first time
and today I bring you a conversation
with a man to whom I owe my life a man
who studies a man whose books a man
who's tireless advocacy have transformed
countless lives across the globe and who
is absolutely instrumental in Paving a
path for my own personal transformation
which is a journey that begins and ends
with my adoption of a plant-based diet
Batman of course is T Colin Campbell the
uninitiated T Colin Campbell is a
Cornell and MIT trained PhD in nutrition
and biochemistry and microbiology
specializing in both nutrition and
toxicology he is perhaps best known as
the author of The China Study which is
one of the most important groundbreaking
massively best-selling books ever
written on health and nutrition and he's
also the author of a book called whole
which is sort of the follow-up to The
China Study Dr Campbell is quite simply
put an absolute pair Paradigm busting
legend of the modern movement for
long-term Wellness I truly hope today's
rollback conversation from April of 2014
educates and inspires you to take your
nutrition take your health and take your
Fitness to the next level and all as a
means to help you unlock and Unleash
Your Best most authentic self so here is
me and T Colin Campbell
I would like to open it up if you could
for the listeners who might be
uninitiated or unfamiliar with your work
if you could simply
synopsize the idea behind The China
Study and what the book is all about
well The China Study of course is a book
uh just 18 chapters but there's only one
chapter that's actually devoted
specifically to the China project itself
I have to point that out because the
whole book is not just about the work in
China right and that's something I want
to explore with you for sure yes it's
the rest of the book The the work that I
was doing
at least if I can say 25 30 years before
I got involved in childhood study that
really played a measure role in my
thinking to try to study in a sense was
getting to a place in time
that I wanted to really have an
opportunity to examine a population to
see if in fact the information we're
getting there was consistent with what I
already had been doing and so to to take
it a step back
um I have this sort of running joke that
in order to be a qualified specialist in
in the plant-based nutrition world you
must have been raised on a farm because
it's you Dr russelston Dr Clapper I mean
I'm feeling very unqualified because I
did not I was not raised on a farm nor
do I have a PhD or an MD but but you you
know you were raised on a on a dairy
farm and and this was very uh
instrumental in kind of informing your
early views about nutrition and health
yeah it really was I mean I was Outdoors
all the time for the most part except
even sleeping Outdoors sometimes and I
mean I really was uh in the dirt you
know plowing Fields Herring fields or
breaking hay of milking cows I milked my
first cow when I was five years old that
was the thing to do and and so um I I
was everything about the outdoors
uh it was my life and I like the
outdoors and I felt totally at home in
the outdoors I I used to say when I was
young that when I got big I would not
take a job inside
which is the opposite has happened so
I've really been uh living if you will
in nature always had a great deal of
respect for nature and and so where did
it uh begin for you in terms of being
interested in in health and biochemistry
and nutrition that was kind of an
accident in a sense not totally
um I went uh to Penn State for my
undergraduate work and in that first
year as was customer and universities we
were given freshmen were given tests to
for aptitude you know future aptitudes
and I took this test and my dad wanted
me to be a lawyer my dad only had two
years of education so I come from a
family that for the most part you know
education was a big thing in any case
he wanted me to be a lawyer so I took
the test and there were about six or
seven or eight different you know paths
I could have followed
law was in the middle so I wasn't too
happy with that I wanted to
[Music]
there were two things that I I suppose
I'm right at the top and one was to be a
farmer I said whoop-dee-doo I know how
to perform
the other was to be in medicine
and that surprised me I never thought
about it but it kind of stuck in my mind
and started thinking about it and I
didn't particularly want to go into
medicine because we lived with a doctor
who you know was on call 247 he had an
old model T4 he came to the homes you
know there wasn't such things as being
in office that kind of thing it was in
the countryside
and I didn't particularly want to do
that for that reason I didn't want to be
on a call all the time very naively I
have to tell you most of my life was
very naive from the very beginning
so but nonetheless I took the idea to my
work in at Penn State to say I'll be
I'll be a veterinarian Mr deck combined
medicine with my agriculture background
so I ended up in veterinary school a
little bit early I just after three
years of undergraduate school
but then in just that of the clear blue
I got a wire a telegram one day from a
fairly famous Professor of Cornell who
had been talking to my advisor at Penn
State
about possible students and so he
offered me a full scholarship to drop
out a drop out of veterinary school come
to Cornell and I thought boy that's
that's a pretty good deal yeah that's
that's you must have been quite the
student uh how did you make that
whatever I don't know what it was he
obviously my advisor Penn State passed
on a good word about me
and uh the thing about it too was what I
say it's kind of an accident happening
time because you know they were going to
pay me to go to school I couldn't
imagine that or you know my dad he
didn't have any more money to hardly see
me through so I thought that was a
pretty good deal too right so I went to
went to a Cornell thinking that somehow
I was going to get involved in maybe in
medical research because it was in the
area of nutritional biochemistry and
pathology
and I went there and I didn't even know
to be honest about it until I was there
about six eight months that I was
actually working for a PhD I never heard
of a PhD that's how naive I was so I it
was just kind of something pulling me in
this way in that way and as I went
forward and
um so I finished up that work in a year
doing actually a masters because I was
being pressured to get to you got your
Masters in one year I did it one year
because I was being pressured by my
draft board I was classified 1A and you
know I had gotten a deferment four times
and they said this is the last time
you've got to go so I had to quit that
fortunately I finished up my degree and
when I was
well I went home went to the draft board
and and I didn't particularly want to go
in the army just being a foot soldier so
I heard about the opportunity I've lived
outside Washington heard about the
opportunity of inquiring about being an
officer so I went and took the test and
there were some rare occasions when you
could do that kind of thing I passed
that I was assigned to be a second
lieutenant
scheduled to report to a hospital in
Colorado it wasn't this is prior to
Vietnam War the Vietnam War at that time
was just starting
and so I was ready to go but then
another professor Cornell wrote me in
the meanwhile
and offered me again a full scholarship
to come and do my PhD I didn't know this
professor and he said come on back he
says you should come back so I took her
to the guy who gave me my commission
that it was supposed to report to and he
said uh well okay go back you know
there's no great pressures right now
we'll keep in touch if you don't hear if
if we if you let us know when you finish
your finish your PhD you ought to serve
your time if you don't we'll contact you
so I figured well I'll go do my PhD come
back and and serve but that by that time
the Vietnam war is getting a little bit
hotter right
and so I didn't hear from them and I was
sort of but as long as you're a student
and you're getting your PhD you're in
the clear right well not until I was 38.
that was the rule of the day you know I
I was I had to take up that officer
appointment until I was 38 which would
have been about 1970 or so and uh
so I was kind of waiting to hear from
them never heard from them and I learned
later that there was a big fire in St
Louis that burned up 30 000 records
perhaps latest records mine was one of
those records that got burned up wow so
it became an unknown person as far as
the Army was concerned wow
um so we have these little amazing
occurrences that are happening a phone
call here telegram here a fire over here
that are all kind of directing you you
know without your righteous awareness
but I was enjoying science in the
meanwhile mm-hmm and uh like you're
getting your PhD in Biochemistry I got a
PhD at that time and nutrition was
biochemistry right nutritional
biochemistry and was there any
specificity to that or what was your
focus
was an animal nutrition so it was
focused largely on trying to improve the
lot of of animals as far as the
nutrition was concerned and uh
I got her offered a couple of positions
as a professor even before I finished my
PhD to go to an animal science
department one back to Penn State to be
a professor of dairy science and so
forth and so I thought something but I
didn't accept that I didn't want to do
that but that time I'd gotten interested
in some other things and the more
fundamental things so I finally finished
up and
and then did some work in a laboratory
where I met my wife as a testing
laboratory near Washington DC where near
where I lived and then there was what
you want to hear all this story I don't
know I said well I mean I'm interested
in understanding kind of how your how
your perspective on nutrition Dairy meat
Etc uh evolved over time from your
perspective when you were a student at
Cornell to what you began to discover
when you undertook uh what you described
in The China Study
yeah it was time went forward I mean
when I was at uh
in this position in this laboratory
doing working right after my PhD I was
there for a short while
uh nice experience but then I got
offered to an opportunity to come to MIT
who by a guy who had been at the FDA to
organize a new Department there in
toxicology so without going into all
those details I got sort of some
training at toxicology too toxicological
biochemistry essentially
then after that it was an offer to go
take a faculty position at Virginia Tech
in a few other places so I went to
Virginia Tech there gotten I started my
research career applying for funding to
do research
and one I had two two tracks which is a
little bit unusual for the day and
wanted to get do some basic science
stuff and the other one was to work in
the international setting which is very
very applied the second one this
International experience was an
opportunity to go to the Philippines and
help organize a nationwide program of
female malnourished children always had
that kind of I had an interest in kind
of serving Society if you will
particularly on an international level I
don't know where that came from but
that's what my interest was in the
laboratory I was working in sort of very
basic biochemical kinds of things well
the two happened just happened to joined
and without my planning because the
Philippines made an interest in liver
cancer and
um you know like I mean Laboratories and
liver cancer go to the Philippines I see
this observation in the Philippines
where children getting liver cancer had
a much higher
um risk of getting the cancer in fact if
there were from families who was a few
families who were consuming them the
best diets high in protein then there
was another report it's so the rest is
history but right so this this fact sort
of lodged in your brain and kind of
compelled you to decide to look into
this further or to design a study to
understand what exactly was going on
right what yeah and as as my career
passed I really got quite active in my
science and at fairly senior levels
actually early on at the national level
being on Iceberg panels and things like
that policy making and I kept scenes I
used all the time and I found it very
troubling and I would ask myself why is
this bothering me and not bothering
others and when I tried to do some if
you will introspection you know what why
do I think the way I think I often came
back to the farm
you know I I would come back this
doesn't sound natural to me if you will
um and so
one of the first question I know I took
a course at Cornell when I first went
there about uh in nutritional
biochemistry and one of the major
illustrations was you know this nutrient
does that another nutrient does
something else and it was a big project
at Cornell at the time involving four
nutrients as it impacted you know a
disease in chickens and calves of all
things and I remember each one of those
four things did something specific
and when but when you kind of mix those
nutrients together
you know then something different
happened right so I asked my professor I
remember at the time I was just a
classroom I was just asking a simple
question but as I look back it's stuck
in my brain because I said to him why
don't we study that this way
he said we can't it's not possible Right
In other words the idea of taking a more
macro approach right and a more global
perspective as opposed to this very
reductionist exactly so that was sort of
lesson number one in a sense as far as
the science was concerned that things
are far more complicated than just
thinking about going from A to B to go
to C and so forth so our biochemical
research when I got involved in that and
I was
lucky to get a quite substantial amounts
of funding from the very beginning and
it continued from NIH from NIH right
yeah and so we had a big research
program actually had a lot of graduate
students and I had the freedom to be
able to ask questions design experiments
see what it might look like and anytime
you learn something new you always have
more questions right so that's that was
the way it went and just kind of drifted
in a certain direction but the more I
just found myself just asking questions
that were a little bit offbeat
I guess because I was just curious I
liked the science
and pretty soon I just
saying started to fall together and I
realized there was a much bigger story
here than just working on one single
thing at a time
but to bring it back to the specifics of
The China Study could you just describe
um the essence of what that was
yeah by the time the China Study
opportunity came along and this was an
early 1980s
um I got a a an opportunity to well it
was a letter sent to Cornell by the
first senior scientist from China to
come to the United States and this
particular gentleman Dr Jen sure sure uh
he had come from a famous family in
China actually in any case he was one of
the first to come to this country he was
looking for a place to land spend some
time his government to give him this
opportunity and he was sent it to
Cornell a little bit and some others
turned it down I don't know why but I
grabbed onto him by the way and so he
came and worked with me
and it was probably one of the best
decisions ever made because it turned
out he really was from a well-connected
family in China for starters and high up
in the government in a sense as far as
science is concerned and so at that time
the Chinese government had done this
Nationwide survey of how much cancer
existed across a total of uh something
like 2 400 counties it was a massive
undertaking and what they were able to
show was that cancer was very common in
some counties and not in others so we
just it was common sense just to ask
what about uh you know what's what's
causing this unusual concentration of
cancer in certain places for about a
dozen different cancers so I just we got
together and I said why don't we try to
get an application to do some funding
there his government was offering
offering a lot of support and kind we
needed Capital so I went back to NIH
again to to see if I could get that
funding we did we had the first project
between the United States and China
first research project at that time so
we went there and surveyed a large
population that was an opportunity for
me to see if in fact the kind of
information we might learn from that
public from that population was
consistent with these rather aberrant
questions that I was getting in the
laboratory and that had to do and those
questions were those crisis were
basically that animal protein in
particular
was promoting cancer because that's what
we learned in the laboratory and uh so
it we did that and measured just a huge
amount of information massive
undertaking I mean imagine people did it
take to sort of collect the data from
this gigantic population of individuals
well it wasn't so big in terms of
numbers of people it was six thousand
five hundred adults plus the family so
we estimate around 10 11 000 people
which in those days what it was big but
if it wasn't that big really what made
it big was the number of variables that
we're looking at and I wanted to be able
to analyze for just anything and
everything because I really was getting
interested in this idea that there's
more to this story as we're generally do
in science than just one thing at a time
so the idea is that you're discussing in
your more recent book whole these are
already formulated and taking place in
The China Study because I think it would
have been very easy for you to Simply
say we're going to look at animal
protein and liver cancer and that's all
we're looking at and we don't need to
look at anything else and nobody would
have batted an eye that is reductionist
science 101 that's the way we do it and
and you could have gone on your way with
that and dismissed with this idea of
entertaining the possibility that an
innumerable number of other variables
could be contributing or having
causative or correlative effects with
the results that you were seeing yeah
actually we proposed for that that Grant
application by the way it's actually
something like that we wanted to look at
the relationship between the minerals
selenium and its relationship to a heart
disease in children that's why in part I
got the grant because I was focused at
the same time we were kind of portioned
in a way because into our party's
interest in the United States and
getting involved in China and vice versa
so for some political support you know I
was able to get it that way but it was
focused on one thing
and so describe what you began to learn
when you say this population with across
all these variables well we ended up
with collecting
367 items of information as I I would
say things measured in the blood the
urine the food of questions being asked
and so we we had a big collection of a
lot of variables if you will we worked
on each one to make sure they're
reliable we had ways of doing that and
then they were all correlated with each
other so we ended with about a hundred
thousand correlations
about nine thousand were sort of
statistically significant
um to be expected that's just the right
random chance of that happening but in
any case we wanted to take those
significant correlations to some others
that might approach significance to see
if there were patterns I should say
incidentally
it was directed by me at Cornell
University but I was able to access some
fantastic colleagues at the University
of Oxford Richard P O Sir Richard Peto
now Sir Richard Allison very eminent
epidemiologists and and and others in
China some of the senior scientists
there
and plus another 24 Laboratories around
the world
and and so what were
some of the most significant
statistically significant correlations
that you began to uncover well it really
coming back to the question of
concerning animal protein I mean that
had been a lifelong or career-long
question because we were able to in the
prior studies we were able to show that
we could turn on and turn off cancer
just simply by feeding of all things the
protein of cow's milk which brought me
back to the dairy farm in a sense and
that was very provocative to say the
least and I think it's you know there
might be a perspective out there that
you were out to you know sort of prove
to establish an objective that you
already believed in but you're coming
from this dairy farm background and it
had been your whole you know the the
conviction of your entire upbringing
that you know milk does a body good that
this is the perfect food right so where
did you start to begin to see kind of
cracks in the in the firmament of that
concept was the initial observation I
think we did was the the the there were
some Indian researchers who had done
some laboratory animal studies that
showed that at the time that I was the
Philippines and but they didn't believe
what they got uh it was published in
obscure Journal but I kind of believed
that because it was consistent with what
I was seeing with the children
and so as we went into that research we
looked at a great depth and I had become
convinced you know by that time we we
did it so many different ways that
animal protein actually increases cancer
risk period and so I was really
interested to know in The China Study
where there was any evidence for that
uh and I mean my bias was to find the
opposite right really was I mean if I if
I had a Prejudice and that's a very
important point you know I think that
that you weren't out to you know sort of
be on this Crusade uh to uh you know
with this foregone conclusion that you
already had in your mind you went out
and you surveyed a gigantic population
of people across innumerable variables
and remained open-minded and uh to take
what you just said hopeful that maybe it
might prove the opposite that's right
absolutely I
was always kind of swimming Upstream
against my own sort of Prior prejudices
but finally the evidence was
overwhelming
with respect to for starters was the
effect of animal protein on encouraging
the development of cancers if you will
but then there were other questions that
arose to at the same time and it always
having this doubt you know about the
significance of this we had asked I
would want to ask broader questions what
if we eat animal protein containing
foods what about all the other nutrients
that come along with it what's happening
there do they cancel each other so we
started investigating all the nutrients
of the cancers all the diseases and the
more that I looked the more to assistant
became the data everything seemed to all
the nutrients in animal-based Foods as
opposed to all the nutrients and
plant-based Foods they seem to be doing
opposite things and and their activities
were sort of mutually supportive
you know it's about chemical and
physiological level so the story became
for me even ever more impressive
was uh but it was always coming from a
position in my case in a sense a woman
was trying to disprove right you know
what I had observed and this is this is
a a landmark Discovery right this is
this had never been sort of established
or presumed or even conjured by anyone
prior to you
it's an interesting question now
Covenant just a minute but yes when we
were doing all the research in the
laboratory and because of my skepticism
about a lot of things what we ended up
discovering were a lot of fundamental
ideas that were against the rules
against what I was teaching against what
was in the books such as well for
example turning cancer on and off by
nutritional means I mean that was a big
deal
and that it turned out we didn't do it
just for protein and liver cancer we
also did it with dietary fat and
pancreatic cancer and things like this
so that that phenomenon of thinking
about the causation of cancer and later
other diseases as a result of Simply
modifying you know nutrient intake and
and the idea of actually reversing
disease right it's the turning over
reversing disease yeah and and cancer I
thought this is incredible
and so we're already learning other
things too like
um that the relationship between
nutrition and genes a lot of people
think and a lot of people still think
that somehow genes
predetermine whether or not we're going
to get a certain kind of disease and
what we are showing no it's not the case
we can have the genes to cause it to
start the initiation of events
but that is we can control it by
nutritional means big thing another one
a sort of principle like if you will an
a like protein it causes cancer let's
say for starters one of the things that
I was really being pushed to do to prove
my point was to find what the mechanism
was you know which enzyme was this was
that and so we started looking for the
mechanisms and it had a series of PhD
students spent in four or five years
each of them looking at a mechanism and
it turned out there is no such thing so
that was another myth that I was all of
a sudden running across too and so a lot
of the things that we we learned really
were I think the result of my skepticism
and it's quite astounding I mean I think
people can inherently wrap their brain
around the idea of prevention like doing
certain things whether through diet or
you know exercise or what have you to
prevent certain things from happening
but when you start talking about
reversal once onset has begun that
starts to get into radical territory
really radical military because the
whole medical profession is in a sense
is sort of supported by the idea the
somehow you're going to be able to if
you have a disease or about the start of
sort of there you know you want to cure
it that's sort of the premise and that's
the that's the territory of the practice
of medicine right what we were saying
what I thought we were saying I'm very
excited about this idea that this
formula this nutritional formula for
preventing the production of fissure
disease also works to treat existing
disease that's the future of this field
just the whole idea you could take this
with people with disease or a very high
risk of disease and
treat them right and so so you're
drawing these conclusions these
statistically significant correlations
and there's a decision at some point
that this should not just reside in a
medical journal but that this should be
shared more broadly through a book right
so where does the idea of a book come in
and how does that all come about well
for the from about the late 1970s until
let's say 1990 I was getting into more
and more trouble if you will by raising
these provocative questions getting
results to show things that were rather
different and I I was a subject of
pretty intense to scrutiny I'd just say
the least from my college but I was
still succeeding in getting all the
money I wanted I had senior positions in
my society and the government yeah the
NIH is smiling down on you I was
thinking of going great and and but
finally you know it became apparent that
I was supporting an idea that I never
expected I would arrive at in the early
1990s when we got the results in The
China Study it supported what we have
been doing in the laboratory New York
Times got a hold of it Jane brought in
one of the leading people writing at
that time for the times I graduated
Cornell too she came up to interview me
she wrote the article it came out in New
York Times times as the the lead article
in the science section and the headline
and it says something like this is the
Grand Prix of all studies it establishes
this out of something else very
provocative and it made me nervous
because by this time you know I'm into
I'm in a science establisher right right
you don't go out and say these crazy
things
and so here are the times I put it in
headline I had to say to myself you're
losing control of this story yeah it's
now it's getting out there and you know
I didn't mind it really getting out
there sharing it with the public to some
extent but this was really provocative
New York Times
and I saw that and I picked up the phone
I called Jane I said Shane why did you
put that title out there like that I
said this is pretty outrageous
and she said he didn't do it she said
the editors did it oh okay so it was out
there about that time so I came home and
asked my wife I did I remember this very
well she does too I said you know you're
willing to live in a double wide
because I figured you know even I
I said I had the senior position of
Cornell the top most topmost position
actually I had an endowed chair I was
and all that sort of thing and I knew
that I was about to take a big hit
one way or another and she said of
course and it was it was I don't know
why yesterday
you could start stockpiling uh guns and
yeah bunker hunker down I I was driven
as she was I mean as I go back in my
background it's very simple we were
really set a farm my wife similarly was
that way no education perfect you know
upper level education for her family or
for mine and I Only Could rely on one
thing and that was the truth and so I
get that from my father
who has had a great reputation as a
farmer in the area of great integrity he
said when you go out don't always says
always tell the truth it was still
assessment was a hard-nosed thing and I
just so you know there's no other way
so I obviously put my toe on the water
and
kept on going and I can't turn back
because that only becomes bigger and
bigger The China Study itself is a book
it was complaining to my wife a little
bit about this is the the arrows come in
my way were becoming more and more
intense and
um
Savannah and she said well once you
wrote a book so I said okay well we will
but I kept putting it off and then she
was getting a little more annoyed with
time and I got a couple of offers from
book publishers in the early 90s that if
I write a book and that came from the
New York Times article if I'd write a
book in one case the guy offered me a
million dollars to write a book and he
wanted to call it the China diet
and I didn't want to do that because I
thought that was corrupt in the message
and so he went back and and back to New
York and actually wrote the first
chapter and wrote the outline and it
then came back says you know I guarantee
a million dollars if you write this book
I didn't want to do it I didn't want to
do it for money that was not the purpose
and so that just sort of sat there for a
while and from 19
I think 92 or three or so until 2002.
when I finally sat down into assistance
with my wife you better write that book
she said
you know it's for the women and the
children the world for no other reason
and tell my story
so wrote it started writing a book with
my youngest son who's now a physician uh
without understanding exactly where this
thing was going to go
and all I wanted to do was just see if I
couldn't summarize for myself a story
that made sense right that was all it
was and we did say in a later lighter
part of the book that you don't have to
believe all this science I said to the
reader just try it
and that's kind of an amazing thing to
pass up I mean a million dollars
so that you could write a book the way
that you wanted to write it and tell the
story appropriately without inflammation
or trying trying trying to sort of frame
the narrative in the context of a diet
that people could purchase right
yeah it was and then I actually after
did The China Study we had the
manuscript ready to go we were shopping
around we I had engaged three other
agents prior to that finally landed on
one that was a good Agent I thought
that's the way to go I didn't know
anything about the publishing business
but in any case this guy had been senior
vice president random house so he wanted
to represent us and he took us he
shopped around to 11 different
Publishers or manuscript and a couple of
them offered advances and I didn't want
the advances because uh the story that
they all wanted they're all consistent
on a couple of points they looked at it
and they said you know you you we don't
need all these references and the public
doesn't want to have all these
references number one they wanted to
dumb it down to the to a 10 year old
that would get rid of the science column
yeah get rid of this stuff and then they
also wanted me to put you know 60 to 70
percent of the book with recipes I said
I don't even know where the pots and
pans are in the kitchen a little recipes
so you know that's not that's not what I
want to do and it's not about the money
you know so I remember a couple of
occasions I won't go into details here
where they were really insisting I was
doing the wrong thing and finally we had
the last meeting with the senior vice
president at the company where this
region had come from and he had to
straighten my tie up and everything else
and tell me how to talk and you know
he's like this this is this is a winner
you know that we're going to go in and
see have this opportunity to meet a
senior person at random house we got in
there and she started saying I started
talking about you know
it's a grander scheme of things and how
things work together no no no nothing
but not possible this is you see they
had published the Okinawa diet I think
it was oh she said are you saying that
you you got there's the same message for
all these different diseases I says yes
that's not possible she got really quite
angry and so I was arguing with it by
Asian intern got annoyed he thought he's
gonna have a big one he could uplift us
right because he I had blown I had blown
the lead no big advance from no bigger
things they both said you know you're
you okay do the book you're not going to
sell more than three to five thousand
copies at the most you know they might
just put it in libraries and standard
stuff so we walked away from 11
Publishers wow just because of what they
wanted to do and the yes they weren't
saying no they just wanted to they
wanted to correct what I was going to do
exactly so I didn't want to do it so
finally went to a small publisher who
allowed us to do what we wanted to do
even he said you're not going to sell
more than
five or ten thousand he says finally he
said if you can sell fifteen thousand I
think it was 15 to 18 000 he said I'll
be happy I'll cover my costs he said but
that's he was just hoping that we could
sell that well now it's well over a
million so made his cup that's amazing
it is it's exceeded a million yeah oh
wow that's incredible but 25 languages
foreign languages wow but it didn't
start out that way uh just in in sitting
down with Howard he told this amazing
story well Howard Howard wasn't involved
no I know but he said he was sort of
recounting the early days of you know
when The China Study initially came out
and how he was the third person oh yeah
the book and it was seven weeks after it
had come out and and yeah I just
presumed that you know when it when it
came out it came out big and strong and
fast and that was not the case like it
took a while before anybody was paying
attention and your little publisher
actually was sort of right in there in
the first few in the first few weeks or
these early days after publication yeah
I I saw on Amazon where these reviews
are written you know obviously I'm
looking at that's all new to me you know
and This brilliant review came out you
know supporting the study and I saw this
guy's name you know Howard Jacobson and
I thought I think I know him you know
because prior to that how he had met had
another someone else and I and so I
thought it was true and of course
memory because Howard's claims that he
stood in line among seven other people
to meet you at the veg Source event and
couldn't even imagine how he you could
possibly remember meeting him but that's
well I I think if I'm not mistaken I met
him through another person other than
John Allen mullenauer oh maybe that's
the case yeah yeah in any case we had a
short meeting obviously but I I it
clearly it became the person that I
thought it was and so that review stayed
on the Amazon site throughout just about
the entire history of the of the 10
years right if you if you're one of the
early reviewers
um good or bad those reviews tend to
stay at the top that's right you know
once the once it really starts to
Cascade unfortunately that was a good
review yeah it's good you're very well
written yeah very positive but what
where was the moment where it kind of
tipped the scales in terms of uh getting
out into the public I mean was there one
thing that occurred that kind of changed
things in terms of getting the book out
there there are certain individuals Gary
Player the
golfer called me up right after it was
it came out and he said I'm Gary Player
uh I couldn't believe that I was talking
to Garrett player but he said that he
was going to be on the Golf Channel with
a big audience and wanted to know if he
could talk about it I said you know help
yourself it's great fantastic he told me
what he's going to do he said I'm going
to get down my knees and and just talk
about this book I mean he was really
impressed with it I guess and so in fact
we watched to see when this happened I
was actually by this time what's Howie
Dr Jacobson
uh and so we watched how we watched Gary
Player get down and you know with the
praying position and it says America
everyone in this country should read
this book or something like that that
was a that was a good hit yeah that's
pretty good that was pretty good and
then um Bill Clinton no publicist is
going to get you that no and then Bill
Clinton came up yeah how does the bill
how does Bill Clinton come into the
equation because this is fast well this
is about two let's see three years after
the book was out and uh I was on the
board with a close friend of Bill
Clinton's a former governor of North
Carolina
uh Jim hunt the board of what no of a
company that my son and I had found okay
and so Jim hunt was on there the cheap
actually we had some pretty key figures
on there but a Jim Honda former governor
of North Carolina was there he in turn
was a close friend of Clinton so Jim
came and asked me if I signed a couple
copies for Clinton
so I did I got a handwritten note back
from President Clinton thanked me for
the book and
he but he never he didn't follow up for
a couple years and it wasn't until the
time of his daughter's wedding right
that he had another problem with his
heart and she in turn the story goes she
in turn wanted him to do the book and so
he got pretty enthusiasted about it and
I got a call from
uh one of his uh Close Associates who
was at the wedding and said the Clinton
had come to the wedding and was carrying
a book with him that's what I was told
and I heard just before the CNN thing
came along but he had the book wasn't he
was showing it everybody and including
Barbra Streisand who wanted to know you
know what is that book here keep on
talking about this is about and this is
second information before the CNN thing
and so he told her and her husband
allegedly said second information again
said to her you know you I got that book
for you two years ago and you never read
it so these kind of stories I always get
any stories and finally then he's on CNN
and this is the Wolf Blitzer prior there
was the the last heart attack show with
Sanji Gupta but it was I remember that
Wolf Blitzer interview where he talked
about
um wanting to be healthy for his
daughter's wedding
yeah it was and he got bigger really
good results and became a real and
serious for this idea
um yes true
that's amazing and then
um where in the timeline does Forks Over
Knives come into the equation
at about that same time and let's say I
think about
2009 possibly this is uh four years
after the book had been published
a young fellow in California had
attended one of militias and this fellow
having some resources
decided that he really loved it and so
forth and so on and I recommended that
he also talked to my friend esselton
because in the book we
I knew esselton he hadn't at that time
really had too much attention so we went
and interviewed him for partly for the
book as you know and and others
and so I recommended he goes hear him
too he did
and the next thing he wants to get
together and put a film out and he said
he wanted to get the best possible
director and producer and he introduced
me to them and wanted to get me to
confirmed the possibility of making a
film you know based on starting out at
least for The China Study that's where
it started at night I sure wasn't
involved in any of that planning
certainly not in the resources or the
return or anything like that I didn't
I mean I haven't gotten any Financial
return out of it so I have no I could be
positioned any of that stuff but he he
followed us the crew followed us to
China to Washington to all over the
place back to my farm the farm we had
when I was a kid and so they went ahead
and
did the film and of course that film has
turned out to be pretty fabulous quite
amazing yeah and talking about it with
Howard
um I don't think anybody could have
predicted what a phenomenon it has
become I think it was the
maybe it still is I'm not sure but for a
very long time it was the number one you
know watched documentary on Netflix or
the number one selling documentary on
Amazon or I don't know exactly what the
statistics are but phenomenal impact
that that movie has had
that has and what's interesting about it
is it's not just about plant-based
nutrition the findings of The China
Study Dr esselstyn's remarkable work
with reversing heart disease through
plant-based nutrition I mean when you
see these angiograms the before and
after it's so compelling but it's also
about this amazing friendship that you
have had for many years with Dr
esselstein and it sort of begs the
question of you know sitting where
you're sitting now
um
you know having devoted both yourself
and Dr esselstyn having devoted the
better part of your lives to this this
Quest and and uh this message that
you're putting out for so many years
having it fall on deaf years or being
criticized or being maligned to now
having you know sort of the the sort of
um audience or reception
um that maybe you thought initially you
might get right out of the gate how does
that feel I mean is that does that give
you a sense of vindication or maybe
that's a little bit of a negative word
but it's been a long road I mean you've
been
you and Essie have been at this for a
very long time and it's taken an
extremely an extremely long time
for the momentum to pick up to the point
where people are now receptive and
hearing it and it's become this thing
it's become this movement
yeah if I get I mean obviously I'm very
gratified you know that this is
happening and as time passes because
deeper and deeper in meeting it for me
and it relates more to more than just
you know working with the biochemistry
you know inside of cancer cells if you
will uh and obviously it's uh led to you
know the possibility of writing another
book as you know and at that time when I
start first started to write the second
book that eventually got called whole
I had in mind the first title was using
the word control
because for me I had a lot of
experiences a lot of Kickback you know
from institutions and other people uh
about this crazy path I was on and it
was very discouraging at times but I I
couldn't I couldn't turn around and I so
I spent three weeks at uh
Resort and not a resort but a beach
house down one before we started right
whole it's called our control and it
started out just documenting all of
these these ridiculous experiences that
I've had the lies you know they existed
in policy and all that sort of stuff and
I wrote about 60 Pages you know in that
period of time and I was going to
document it that way and all of a sudden
it struck me this is really stupid you
know why am I talking about all this
horrendous Kickback it made no sense
and so I said well forget that so I
decided to go back and write a book that
was more positive try to understand you
know rather than talk about all the
negative stuff coming my way right I
mean it would kind of come off as sour
grades that's right exactly and I just
didn't have any any
taste for that whatsoever I wanted to
write something just asking myself is
there something about this idea that's
missing from the
from our work in science
and the more I thought about it I
started out with three to Define three
words nutrition medicine health I didn't
know how I was going to Define it but I
knew it wasn't what I was teaching and
had been teaching over the years and
stuff like this and no research didn't
show that and the reductionist idea had
been mentioned in The China Study so
that was there
but then I didn't know how to describe
the rest of it so if I know it's holism
it's something something like that and I
saw and I want to spell it out I went to
three dictionaries to learn if you know
I was going to spell it w h o l i s m it
always has been spelled h-o-l-i-s-n
and I thought I'd find an alternative
spelling I couldn't find it right and so
then I decided you know I'm going to
create my own word here put it put the
dubbing foot move presses around it and
called it holism and then I got into
reading some if I was a total amateur
you know in the history of
um a little bit of religion if you will
the ancient Greek times and stuff like
that and got some ideas and this the
more I thought about the concept of holy
man this is this is pretty good you know
because it really just all of a sudden
is like a step in a new world new
paradigm almost taking a Step Beyond
holistic into the wh
holism and the idea of taking this
global view of understanding and
embracing the idea of the incredible
complexity of
nutrition diet biochemistry human
physiology and an appreciation I think
for how difficult it is to draw
conclusions from a reductionist approach
is that fair to say fish very fair to
say in fact now I'm really kind of
immersed in the idea of really
challenging the whole concept of what we
regard as science I mean science is in
biology in the biological world in the
medical world so-called science it's
larger reductionists of course we all
know that it's caused a lot of harm and
a lot of difficulties yeah and but I
understand the need to do reductionist
research because that's what I was
involved into in the beginning but it's
sort of the threads of the tapestry
everybody can work on their own spread
you know and make a big deal out of it
what the tapestry might look like but
they have no clue
what's in their imagination these
threads impact each other yeah so it's
only you know by putting all these
threads together
do we begin to see something new and
something exciting and so I kind of like
that metaphor as much as any other
so how do we you know how do we move in
a New Direction with this I mean what is
the solution I mean I I would presume
that you still maintain that a
reductionist approach is appropriate in
certain circumstances for certain
purposes sure but how do we how do we
take this newfound idea that you're
proposing and Implement that into a
better way of approaching science
well you know reductionist research I I
don't want to come back off you know is
actually be opposed to production of
research I'm certainly have not because
those we have to have this register to
make the tapestry that's fair enough and
I'm glad there are reduction of
scientists building my airplanes that I
ride on or building my computers you
know they I want them to be precise I
want them if you just do it as best they
possibly can as they put that together
but in biology and medicine all one
needs to do is go look at the cell
you know the the between whatever is 10
to 100 trillion cells we have in the
body just look inside of one of those
cells and see this extraordinary
complexity
which in itself every cell is just
virtually almost like our universe
it's the micro Cosmos it's the macro
components if you will and and see this
enormous Integrity that occurs in
Symphony it occurs within the cell
and that's for me in a nutshell what
this is all really all about and where
as to where we go with this in the
future I think your spiritual is a
really big thing people have to simply
try it like we said in The China Study
you don't have to believe me just try it
and that that and so what is it that
they're trying well just eating a whole
food plant based up right okay yep
without adding back
the oil the fat the sugar that they've
become accustomed to just eating the
whole food plant-based diet it's an
awkward term it's not exactly veganism
or vegetarianism because they come up
short you know in this but nonetheless
they were going in the right direction
and I we said we now know and thanks to
my friend Dr esselton and Dr ornish and
some others who were from in Dr Greger
Dr Clapper yeah especially but
assassilton really assassin and orange
um and Dr Clapper yeah
uh there's a
we but when what I got really enthused
about their work uh as much as anything
else that confirmed what we had been
doing in animals reversing cancer which
is just about that Furthest Thing One
could have in their mind reversive by
nutritional means I mean that
really kind of sealed the deal for me in
many ways that biologically speaking
we were turning cancer on and off by
nutritional means that we were doing it
by multiple sort of holistic sort of
approach in that sense in controlling
genes in the process that's all those
so-called principles I had worked on
years ago while it was something to come
at the light when I
when Dr Aston called me after the New
York Times article
and then I found out what he was doing
[Music]
the heart disease aspect yeah I said
geez you you're doing exactly and he did
his thing or from his perspective and it
was really nice which came to the same
place right yeah it's beautifully
orchestrated yeah
um we're running out of time and I could
spend the entire afternoon taking up all
of your time
and you've been very gracious to uh to
um spend this time uh
with uh
with us but I wanted to
um
I think I would be remiss if I didn't
uh raise the issue of the critiques of
The China Study the the sort of
um
dismissals that are out there and
there's a lot of people that listen to
this podcast that are coming from
different kinds of nutritional protocols
and you go online it's very easy to be
confused and there's conflicting
opinions and it can kind of create a
paralysis in terms of what to do and and
and like many things in life something
comes out that's new and revolutionary
and it takes a while for it to come into
the mainstream and then it's celebrated
and human nature is to then after five
minutes later let's see if we can pull
this down and attack it and uh and there
are certain contentions out there uh
that's
that uh have proposed that The China
Study has been debunked it's like become
this popular thing well didn't you hear
the time The China Study has been
debunked and and I'm interested in in
how you weather
um those kind of comments and and what
your response to that is
well first off I should point out those
people who are writing this kind of
information have no training in science
in their social science number one they
know experience to do any kind of
experimentation they don't publish they
don't they're not being held accountable
for what their words
they could say anything they want to say
in science you know we we developed some
evidence and and if it's going to be
worthy of consideration we publish it
and it's being reviewed by peers now we
don't publish it if it doesn't pass that
muster and my work was was reviewed
extensively first off in actually
competing for funding only one of every
six applications gets funding when we
just continue to get funding for 27
years for that one project I had a lot
of success in getting funding and so I
had a pretty good name actually you know
in a scientific world for doing good
science
then when you publishing I have over 300
and some Publications that were peer
reviewed so I'm held accountable for my
words let me tell you even by my critics
these people writing this stuff have
nothing none of that
that's a that's a very important point
to make good writers great writers but
they don't have this background they can
say anything they want to say and they
say just totally untruthful things but
let's if we come down there's a couple
of observations that uh the people who
have all these Atkins like diets if you
will and paleo diet and all all those
books different names different authors
different times they're all basically
the same thing they're all talking about
a low-carb diet
that's become the Mantra of the day well
since plants are the only kind of
Foods essentially to have carbohydrates
really serious and also carbohydrates in
them this is really has been an attack
on the recommendation we should be
consuming vegetables fruits and Grains
as a means of Health from the very
beginning
I mean Atkins came out in 73 with their
first book that was following the
McGovern thing that you know said to
delete eat less animal food so the low
carb diet
the better name for that they should be
called a high protein high fat diet and
there is no evidence I find no evidence
in scientific literature any place else
that you can actually take that that
kind of diet and treat and reverse
disease it's simply that's the one thing
that always brings me back to a whole
food plant-based diet is that is the
only protocol that I'm aware of that
actually has had significant success
reversing illness and I don't think any
other protocol can make that claim and
suddenly you know in recent years it's
become very Vogue to talk about
grass-fed meats and putting butter in
your coffee and the supposed cholesterol
myth and fat is not your enemy and all
of these sorts of things and and and and
and I mystified I'm mystified as to how
this could suddenly be the case I mean
every cardiologist I've spoken to you
know every medical practitioner that I
respect does not adhere to these to
these ideas that are out there and I
don't know whether it's there is some
science to support something that I'm
not understanding or whether people just
want to hear good news about their bad
habits but what is your perspective on
that well it's always possible since
they're not being held a cattle for
their own sort of interpretations if you
will they're able to choose rather
reductionist kinds of ideas and threaded
together to make it sound like a halfway
decent story at times some of them can
and the good college good calories bad
calories is one such book where the
writer is a good science writer good
journalist but he pulls from the
literature you know observations are
very subject guys pull us together makes
it sound like a reasonable story so it's
used in reduction of Science in that
sort of fashion but the point is that
as I say they cannot treat people with
disease together they can in some of
these diets of course lead to some loss
of body weight and to me that's pretty
consistent that's that's one thing
um and to some extent the blood
cholesterol has come down a bit too but
in reality with their passage in some
time most of them drop off the wagon
don't continue it from some short-term
you know adverse effects but in the long
term
no one can tell me that they can find
societies of large groups of people who
are consume a high protein high fat diet
for all their lives and seeing lower
rates of cancer don't you know about the
Inuits
they come up well the Inuits of course
are the people who tend to die early for
stars and the major cause of death is
trauma
so they don't quite live into the period
when they might otherwise might get
problems but there has been research
showing in fact that there are problems
are not quite so severe as much given
how much protein and fat they presumably
consumed
um it's uh it's not all all what has
claimed to be well I suppose that
they're they're they may be a genetic
outlier also because they've adapted in
a certain environment in isolation for
many years I mean there could be but it
but it's such a statistically
insignificant I mean it's such a small
group of people
to but there seems to be a like an
inordinate amount of focus on that
particular Community as opposed to the
planet at large all right well there's
another group that's a better
illustration I think and this is the
messiah in Africa who blood meat and
milk right that's their lives it's also
said they don't have any problems their
cholesterol levels are low and they
don't have a heart disease and so forth
and so on it turns out the principal
person who was first reporting this
so-called low cholesterol levels
actually in 1973 when he went back and
had a chance to examine 50
massage who had died otherwise he just
wrote in his conclusion all these men
had atherosclerosis equal to that of old
American men hmm
so they actually do not in fact have the
really low cholesterol levels you know
don't you know don't have that the
effects of atherosclerosis this is the
man who first told is often gets quoted
George Mann was his name you know as
telling about the Messiah having these
Remarkable Health advantages but in 73
he probably something quite the opposite
so to explain this in a sense they
actually are able to apparently they
exercise they should just ignorant
amounts of exercise obviously something
like yourself
and so the exercise is a big place a big
role and they actually are able to form
these collateral vascular Network around
somebody's lesions possibly and so
they're able to
survive and extend you know and do quite
well in this for for some period of time
they don't live very they don't live
again to that age where we can really
get good data on that point but
um it's this story about the Messiah and
those kinds of people oftentimes you go
back and really check to see what
evidence is being used this is sort of a
citation of some early literature that
you know somebody made some observations
that weren't reliably examined it
certainly is true with the Messiah and I
had the first the first Messiah student
to come to the west to do a doctor she
came to work with me at Cornell I gave
her some money to go back and her father
had been a doctor I guess a traditional
doctor in the Messiah group and so I
asked her if they're going to collect
some more information you know to see
because I wanted to know more what they
were really eating and of course she
came back and they were eating a lot
more tubers and Roots like that than
hadn't previously been reported then it
happened to also be a friendly got to
know one of the leakies the wife of one
of the Reiki sons who lived in the in
the midst of that group for 20 years and
when she I was talking to her about that
and that's where she says I spent 20
years of her life in the massage
tribal region she said that their claim
that they only eat meat milk and eggs is
not true interesting they do eat a lot I
mean that's very clear right but when
we're Gathering and Agri they do
certainly do some together present
interesting but that's the limit of my
knowledge I can't tell too much more
about that right
all right well we got to wrap this up
but uh I want you to tell us a little
bit before we go uh about this new movie
Project that's underway
um yeah the the
four seven eyes as such great success uh
my oldest son has uh actually engaged
the services of the director
of four seven eyes
and also one of the cool
co-producers of fortunatives John Corey
quite a experienced fellow right I know
John do you know John yeah he's on
burning pressure John and was Lee and
they both are excited about what's
happening here I can't tell too much at
this point in time or
actually there's a one event in
particular that's going to set it apart
it's happening right now what we're
sitting here talking today you're such a
tease you're teasing us now I'm not
changing it I'm not changing I just got
an email this morning I can't wait until
you're in a gag order oh so oh I can't
say I all I all I can say is I'm
enthusiastic for what this is turning
out to be because force of knives are
sort of telling the public here here's
some information that's kind of useful
and what you might use in your lives and
so forth and so on it was just became
very popular but it didn't really answer
the question why why hasn't this been
not been told before
this goes to that question
and it it goes right to the heart of it
I can't imagine not even told in the
sense of why why you know why has it
been so difficult to penetrate the
American Consciousness with these ideas
yeah right right I mean I've become
really very interested in the history of
this whole field of nutrition and Cancer
Research in particular you know often
ask myself oh is it taking so long right
you know because we had this information
that's another whole story we had a lot
of this information back in the 1800s
it was brilliant it's fantastic for
giving this resources they had I've got
11 books in fact written by a gentleman
in the middle 1800s who was a doctor
until he's 41 he was a surgeon a doctor
when he was 40 what he got to be age 41.
he became a vegetarian
and then he wrote a total of 11 books
eventually it was elected to the Irish
Academy of Science
and he these books are incredible he's
talked he's warning against going down
the road to visit Pharmaceuticals in
those days is suggesting that cancer for
example is not a disease I thought it
was that is a local disease you could
treat very specifically it was a
constitutional disease
so you're talking about a whole body
you're talking about holism
and he was right and he's
extraordinarily interesting
texts but he wasn't able to connect with
the public he got forgotten and so the
idea is I mean I I would presume that
this gets into politics and money and
all sorts of
private interest and things like that
that that sort of work together to kind
of
prevent certain kinds of awareness from
penetrating it was during the Advent of
the Industrial Revolution
it really was and so a lot of things
were being invented like the microscope
and breathing refined and other kinds of
instrumentation to special photometric
sort of instrumentation to be able to
see things and concentrations and so
forth and so on
radioisotopes came into play in the you
know late 1800s were being used to track
you know their course of nutrients and
other things through the body and I mean
there's some very powerful uh
instrumental methods were coming to the
fore and people in the science wanted to
play with these things and it was it was
fascinating stuff right so they ended up
looking at
individual things individual nutrients
and all the rest so the birth of
reductionism the birth of rhinocism I
I've got a lot I've I've written I've
heard A Long paper actually almost a
book on this whole history and I found
some really amazing statements made
during the 1800s and early 1900s and the
founder of the Cancer Society the
American Cancer Society found that in
1913
he had already had a name for himself
near tuberculosis
he founded that Society
and advocated that one of the things
this new Society should do as far as
cancer is concerned pay some attention
to nutrition which is totally off the
charts radical yeah and he's three years
later he was thrown off the board of the
organization that he founded wow and in
1922 nine years later they held the
First National Conference International
Conference actually two presenters there
were were tasked with the idea of
basically really criticizing this
founder
um
interesting this this stuff has been
going on for a long time right right
right and and are these ideas that are
going to be
addressed in the in this documentary
or it's a sort of current context not
not so much version of that is the yeah
the current content is more a derivative
of that kind of thought
um
yeah I
wish I could tell you more but we'll
have to wait and see it's supposed to be
out in September I don't want to say
September or oh really that's that's
that's not that that far off no it isn't
as most of us filmed and we but still
you know it's uh uncertain end right and
I don't want to overstep my bounds and
you know for that reason either because
it
the events of I don't I don't see how
what's about to transpire today is I
don't think it's it's going to hurt hurt
the film at all but one never knows the
world is an unpredictable place that it
is and uh that is a perfect cliffhanger
to
conclude the conversation so we will
look forward with uh baited breath to
September do we don't we don't know what
the title is yet though it has a title
uh I'm not particularly fond of it but
my myself but others seem to like it for
some reason it's called plant pure
Revolution plant pure Revolution I think
it's a mouthful I'm not sure it sounds a
little bit academic to some people it
sounds a little bit too provocative I
guess I don't know
I'm just not prepared to say right all
right I wish I could have a if I had
Howard Jacobson with me to come up with
a title I'm sure with all his metaphors
and things like that I'm sure he can
come up with something better he come up
with something well let's call it the
working title maybe that will change by
September
all right well Dr Campbell it was a
honor and a and a privilege to sit down
with you thank you very much you are an
inspiration you're a gift to humanity
and I appreciate your work tremendously
and it's been fantastic to be able to
spend a little time with you on this
course I really thank you for this
opportunity it's fantastic your story is
also so inspirational it's beyond belief
I have to say number one but number two
I just would like to add this little uh
footnote
um you know there was a famous study
that was done in early 1900s by a
physiology professor at Yale University
uh on the question concerning the role
of a plant-based diet he didn't call it
that on athletic performance no I didn't
know that now amazing results
published in two books one and I think
1905 and the other 1907 I believe uh-huh
his name is Russell Chittenden
c-h-i-t-t-e-n-d-e-n
and he did it on himself first right he
started using this kind of diet felt
better in all the usual
uh then he got some other fellow
professors to join him to do this and
they felt better too and then he worked
on some uh young students who were
coming into the ROTC program at Yale
getting trained for the next six months
physically and otherwise
so we put them on a plant-based diet
essentially
not the diet they had come from home on
you're high in animal protein put them
there he recorded he'd put him through
15 strength and endurance test at the
beginning in October of that year he
came back in April same test again you
could see the numbers slope up all of
them it was impressive when they went on
this diet he got criticized by his
fellow of colleagues uh that would work
you know that's that's crazy they they
improved because they were being trained
it had nothing to do with it he said
fine so he went out and got some a
couple of All-American athletes and
really into is he already trained
already trained peak of their peak of
their condition as he called it their
numbers were near the top
you know they were already at that level
right they put them on play at this date
and just jumped way up wow that was
published in at that time and then can
you still I would love to read that is
there yeah I can get that information
for you yeah I would love to be able to
so you're living proof of what you know
he right so what I'm saying is nothing
new it's been well I don't want to say
that you you've taken 100 years ago
you've taken a whole new whole new level
but uh yeah and I think that what you
have done in some other you know
obviously world-class athletes that I've
come to know too
have just there's some amazing athletes
out there uh doing incredible things and
in no small part due to uh your tireless
work so
it's just beginning it's just because I
agree uh it's exciting times I'm
optimistic and uh I think that
there's a lot of work ahead for myself
and for you but it's very encouraging uh
to
see what's happening and to be for
example on this boat and to have the
experience of connecting with so many uh
people that are having incredibly
dramatic uh changes in their life by
adopting this New Perspective and it's
touching and
um you know it's a it's a it's a life
work uh that uh this fun is fun and um
and meaningful so thank you thank you
peace
plants
[Music]